okay welcome to another wolf and
language design review part about
incremental language development series
and we are looking at some things that
were supposedly low-hanging fruit
defined a decade-ish ago or a little bit
less
right we've got some items from user
interface here oh all the stuff here
yeah I'm gonna emphasize supposedly
there in some of the these cases
which I didn't remember my sentence
supposedly
supposedly low hanging yeah right
okay so one of the issues that I think
was part of this or maybe that's key
press pain is this thing about can you
make a full screen
uh interface
which
and I think maybe that is key press pain
it's like people you know the endless
kids who want to write games in our
language and things like that
and they say can I just take over the
screen and press the the the t button to
have my total jump
yeah yeah well I mean you know to be
honest uh I remember when key press pain
was proposed and
there just hasn't been a lot of oomph
behind it I I don't hear
um
you know a lot of demand for it
look I think in the educational sector
of kids who want to do games there would
be some demand the question is how hard
is it to do and do we have a credible
design
um well the design is
uh
yeah I'm I'm not a hundred percent for
sure to be honest the you know we we can
handle key presses right now but I I
don't I don't have a good sense off the
top of my head for example uh you know
how well we deal with uh you know it's
you know things like you want to not
just know that a key was pressed but is
it is it when does it go down when does
it go up uh you may want to have some
kind of repeating action behind it or
you may just want to know the down and
up events
um
right well I mean but but this design
basically just says
this is about key presses and it says
when you press the command a do this
yeah well maybe that's not the right
thing I mean maybe maybe it's not
realistic well I mean there's uh but
you know what if
I mean there's a there's a weakness in
what's being suggested here in terms of
uh you know do you want independent
things when you press command and when
you press a you know it's you may want
it independent or you may want it
together
I understand but I think those things
that's a standard kind of you know which
pattern comes first type story
and I I'm not too worried about that I'm
more worried about let's say you press
one of these things and you want the
result of the press to be some kind of
edit of what you see on the screen
we don't have a great way to do that
maybe maybe we do maybe maybe it's just
Dynamic but it seems like you're writing
something very additive what you see on
the screen that I you move forward you
press the arrow the turtle moves right
right now it's easy for us to have
something where the whole
of the screen content is dynamic and
there is a variable updated you know
when you press right arrow it just says
X plus plus or something for the x
coordinate you know what I'm saying yeah
but I don't know whether that's even
vaguely credible in terms of how that's
working
in you know is that useful to do that
and have it be basically a screen you
know a complete Dynamic refresh
does that make sense
well I mean for something like a game
you need a loop
um
and the loop is going to have things
that are changing regardless of whether
or not events are happening the events
will influence the loop but the the loop
runs independently of the events
I think this is a separate look this
topic is too complicated for this you
know keyboard event handler that seems
to be the junior version of this and
that seems like it is much more doable
well and I I'm not sure I I remember key
press pain I do not remember keyboard
event handler I'm not sure
event handler
yeah I mean I'm not sure what the
difference is between this and event
handler
well what how do you make can I make an
event handler that does something when I
press the letter A
yeah
I believe so
uh yeah yeah key down I mean is so I
mean yeah this is documented an event
handler that's uh key down and you can
just specify the key right yeah right
there
okay
so
what what would I do here let's say I
want to turn this from red to blue
I would say dynamic
what do I say a dynamic if
you know
well Dynamic of X here yeah yeah I mean
you need some some X initialized to red
and then
with the dynamic module
sure
Dynamic module let's make it simple just
x equals zero or yeah whatever yeah and
then red and then what I want to say
here is a goes to
um a that thing there x equals blue
yeah I mean that's not the documented
syntax but
what is the documented syntax that melts
down in a sub list key down
list of key down comma a
okay just for jollies
now the tricky thing about what you're
constructing here the little key up has
to go back
no actually actually there's something
trickier
um uh
the tricky thing here is that it will
only snag uh
events when it has Focus yeah
so you know you have to you have to get
the focus in uh and yeah I mean no this
is almost a joke
yeah yeah I mean you know you could you
know wrap a panel around it or something
uh oh so I wrap a panel around this
uh no no no no it would it has to be
inside the X
you can also use cell event actions or
notebook event actions to have this work
at a higher level guys we've already
lost the game here I mean real estate
yeah I mean well you know I mean in the
context of so there's an interesting
thing that happens with web games uh
where uh a lot of web games uh and this
was I don't know how much you know this
might not be as much of an issue with
HTML games but it used to be a huge
issue with flash games where uh the very
first thing that a flash game would get
you to do is Click inside the you know
the flash area and that's because if you
hadn't clicked in the area it couldn't
snag any events and so it would like
have a start button that you'd have to
click with a mouse but that was just a
trick it was a trick to get focus into
the flash widget
um and there's you know conceptually
it's a similar sort of thing here
okay look this could do a little bit of
packaging maybe I mean
let's not address it here is there a
person I don't think this is super high
priority but this by the way should
probably be on the global project this
because it's a it's a um it's a slightly
bigger story
okay I mean it's basically
and if you have somebody in your group
who could take a little look at this
John and just try and you know because
obviously this is unusable basically we
you know by the time well it is
clear if if we made it usable in the way
you just described it would it would
become unusable in the opposite
direction you know no no I understand
that I got it but I mean the the fact is
that by the time you've got enough
little idioms here that have to be set
up we really need a function that just
does this
okay plus a little bit of ux stuff here
about whether this is active or not and
you know some some way of of of making
it clear that it's active by having some
you know paid you know border around it
and so on just some packaged thing where
it is where there's a a hover effect
that says inactive or something click to
activate or some such other thing well
and and that's why that was kind of the
idea behind key press pain I I don't
really know what the idea behind
keyboard event handler is I'm not sure
that remember it's following but yeah
but key press paint that was sort of the
idea well then that's what we need maybe
it's just this basically with just a
little bit of wrapping I mean at least
that will be a place to start it's just
this with the wrapping necessary to make
it actually usable
yeah
let's let's plan on trying to do that I
mean it doesn't seem very hard I mean
and not get into all the tentacles just
see whether we got anything reasonable
there and take it from there
well and I mean and you know in talking
about key press pain I mean you could
argue maybe it's a vet Handler pain
because you know does key press only
take key events yeah why why not have it
be about to handle pain
that might be the right thing
but take a look at that okay let's keep
going
font weight numeric values what on Earth
is this
um I don't know and and this is by the
way yes yeah by the way I I should say
that I I mean I I went through the kind
of list of topics but I did not dig deep
into any of these I think all this is is
saying we've got font weight Style
you know
and we've got font weight
Arrow
you know and we have a bunch of them
yeah but they're all string selectors
yeah
okay but the the I think the only Point
here is is there a values having numeric
values does it is that a thing now known
in the world
um well in HTML
um I understand but if people if that if
that means that font designers have
designed a weight 200 font
then we should might as well plug into
that
that will be a question I don't know so
uh Adrian I think you need to take that
to Jeremy or somebody to find out yep I
don't know
okay I mean the implementation is
straightforward the question is does
anyone care right
and if if the implementation is
straightforward we might as well you
know there's an argument we might as
well do it unless people say well that
was a proposed thing but then there was
a rebellion and font designers decided
not to do that and yeah or people
disagree on that what the numbers should
mean or yeah yeah but it's a question
for a designer
okay let's move on
browse View
okay well this is an important thing
this is
related to the modernization of short
right well I mean expression browsing
sure I'm not sure about some of these
other things but uh expression browsing
yes
right I mean this is the alighted notion
of just being able to put something that
says it's a lighted into an expression
and you know you press the dot dot dots
and it opens up now it also relates I
guess to iconize
yeah I mean iconize has been very
successful but I agree
there's sort of a question
you know maybe there's a more Dynamic
version there is there is an open uh in
ux uh this is with Noah but Noah you
know has a lot of projects right now so
it's you know not turning over super
quickly but uh but there is an open
project for you know uh General
expression folding and how we might just
you know have a fully interactive
experience with that as opposed to the
iconize experience which is partially
interactive but you know has a few
issues well I mean the question for
iconize is a slight redesign of iconize
might mean I never thought about this
before but short could simply spray
iconized into into things
so I I am not going to comment on
changing shorts you were talking to the
wrong person about changing shorts
you know it's a mythical creature I mean
because you know I wrote the original
Short
and
I'm rolling my eyes slightly yeah you
you you wrote the textual short which is
different from the box World short
okay
uh time Tom wrote The Box World short
which twj yeah okay
um
let's see
gosh in ancient times probably uh
yes in like 1995. yeah version three
yeah
okay so I mean the question there is
the thing you get
in
you know in the shortified version
you know that thing is just crazy that
thing's a version three creature I mean
look at it look at the craziness of that
you know why isn't that
what would happen if that was simply
replaced by an iconize
well the uh uh if the iconize held the
actual data
then uh that would be a disaster a
consequence is that if the data were
large that data would get shipped to the
front end
um and that in some cases that would be
quite undesirable okay fine but so this
is an example of what we have in a
zillion different cases which it I think
has become the world expert on of things
that have remote
you know you know what I'm saying
yeah I mean things where you can choose
you know we don't have this as a concept
and iconize but instead hello
we have a concept of a thing which has a
kernel imprint that could be populated
in the front end why doesn't this I'm
sorry I thought this was supposed to
display maybe that's coming in 13 2 and
I'm not running 13 2 here I thought that
displayed go ahead maybe it's small
enough that it doesn't think it's worth
it to save in a file ever no it is saved
in a file that's its file
oh never mind
I think it's just stupid I mean it it
it's not supposed to work that way
what's that what version are you running
well thirteen one so let them that may
be completely unfair
let's just check this but I mean my
basic point is this here could be
exactly the same story because it's the
same type of thing it's like it got
really big you do really want to save
that in a file I mean and you know do
you really want to ship that to the
front end we should be using the same
mechanism for that as we're using for
these other things well so we don't have
an uh an option for iconize to do this
and maybe we should
yeah maybe we should maybe that's the
the right solution that iconize could
store its data in the kernel
I like that idea uh I'm not sure I like
that idea right I mean part of the the
right point of iconize is that you have
it in the notebook and maybe what we
need is a generalized iconize
to be clear what I'm proposing is would
not be a change to the default behavior
of iconize it would be an option that
you could invoke if you specifically
want the uh it's in the kernel and
provide an interface to pull it in if
you really wanted look at this this is
nice this is nice what we have here
right it says external file and then it
says change storage location
that will be a nice thing for iconize
that you could say that there's a
version of iconize where you could say
you know iconize
range of 100 and now where I could say
here what the storage location is yeah
there's there's
well the um
maybe I don't know this persistence
location there's a method option right
iconized as a method option so we could
add
well I'm not sure it should be obscure
as a method option but I I'm um
right but the method option already
controls how it's stored
so oh wow
I didn't know that
I didn't even know we could do that okay
so to be honest I had forgotten that as
well
why doesn't it why doesn't it do that
what does it do automatically
it it stores the actual expression
because that's the only thing that's 100
guaranteed to be the same
really binary serialize isn't guaranteed
to be the same nope
isn't there like packed array
stuff with binary serialized for example
well I mean there are two issues one is
right the expression is going to be like
binary deserialize of some byte array
rather than the actual experience I see
I see I see
um which isn't really what we want I
mean why doesn't it Auto deserialize
uh because it has to store some
expression inside and that's the
expression that's stored I mean there's
no such if you don't have a valuation
there's no such thing as Auto I see okay
fair enough
um and right and then you know there are
various edge cases with binary
serialized and deserialize with you know
like pack with sparse arrays or other
um you know Atomic objects so
um
okay so hold on
look this is I think a very good idea
that we're on to here a version of
iconize that can store its data remotely
in exactly the same way as this
and again maybe it shouldn't be called
iconize it should be called
I mean just for one you know for a name
we could call it external iconize or
something
except it isn't necessarily
right and then the the idea would be it
basically is just an interface to this
exact mechanism here
am I making sense
yeah I mean well that's not can't
literally be true but I understand but
but then then we could have a version of
short
that specifically makes these things be
things where this is either just in the
kernel or it's a short where where the
notebook has to refer to some external
Cloud object or God knows what else to
get that data that's there
and most of the time that data would
just go into La La Land because it's a
session based you know piece of Kernel
data
yeah I mean what would be a little weird
right that's that's not really right
that 76 isn't really an expression right
it's a sequence that's a part of iconize
deals with that iconize can deal with
that well I mean
it can deal with the fact that it can it
can create a sequence that's not the
you know again that's not exactly
equivalent to what you started out with
whatever
it may not be perfect but it's gonna I
mean that's already will be super useful
to have this instead of this right to
have an external iconize in here that is
like this that has that 76 element thing
in it by the way I do think the default
display of sequencing and iconize should
be something that has a number shouldn't
It Maybe not maybe not it doesn't always
isn't always wanted
look this is the thing we should be
doing this is a good idea
to basically have something where it's a
version of short
that uses
session based you know kernel backed
iconized
okay who who here can take this and and
develop it
Nick
I don't think that's that's not for John
it's not for your group yet who did the
original iconized
doesn't who did do the original iconize
now it was some combination of me and
Lou okay by the way this iconized seems
to be below the it seems to be have
dropped below the Baseline somehow
strangely
it's trying to align the text inside it
probably I don't know but
um
I mean it's uh
uh it may be something that makes more
sense if it happened to have curly
braces uh in it uh because remember
curly braces line up on the axis points
it looks wrong to me
I think it's a bug it does look like the
Ellipsis is Baseline aligned though
yeah but I don't think it looks right I
mean that's a design question
I I just don't think this looks right
did it get bigger
no
that's also wrong
come on that's wrong
well that right that's not text right
it's that's that's a graphics Graphics
doesn't
resize with bonds well I mean it can't
necessarily it can yeah I mean I mean it
can be made to resize I think it's just
a bug I think this should resize
period end of story I think it should
resize and its Baseline is wrong
okay so Avery that's for you to chase
it's a bug
got it
okay now in terms of who can look at
this
Nick I mean is this something for you I
could certainly take a look at it I'm
not super familiar with the iconize code
itself but I could always ask it's
highest but it's high and lower probably
the people to talk to well and and and
also I think some familiarity with what
was done for audio and friends who did
that who did that
well it was audio was Carlo with you
know help from me and Lou right okay
fine so maybe maybe Carlo yulu Nick can
get together and talk about this I think
this is a really good idea this external
iconize I think this will be a great
solution for short I think we can just
do it
okay that all these things will turn
into essentially kernel based
iconization
where they have some kind of button that
allows you to say store it
Etc makes sense
yeah we can certainly start a
conversation about that fine and then
they they you know this thing might have
a nested iconization so you press one
button here it iconizes that and
Etc okay
all right I think that's the right
version that's the that's the future of
a lighted Elida was something I've
thought about for like a decade but I
think this is a better approach this
iconize version
makes sense to people
yeah sure okay let's move on
stop
huh this is the first I'm hearing of
this
I mean with progress indicators you
people can opt in to a stop button if
they're
uh you know
uh I see what you're saying that would
be very interesting this is different
though isn't it different but what
you're suggesting which I think is a
good idea is stoppable
of expression
how is this not interrupt
I I think this stopped things more like
pause than stop yes it is I mean I I
think it's it's for it's for if you're
running some long thing and you
basically want it to to tell you oh by
the way here's the some intermediate
results but I'm not done yet
but you should look at this result
before I continue second an example I
can imagine using this for is like
you're processing some giant data set
and it's going to take it 30 minutes but
you know uh but you know at minute 15 it
encounters some weird situation and it's
going to pause and ask you should I
continue is this okay
and right yeah why aren't you using
dialogue then
a function we never use isn't that just
like Choice dialogue
because that blocks the kernel in
weights
it very well may be
but I've never used Choice wouldn't you
have to block here in order to you would
input yeah you would
okay so I mean I mean there are
certainly various uh not just Choice
dialogue there's other similar sorts of
things uh if you're running a notebook
product that you can do
um message dialogue dialog input
right I don't think we ever think about
those things because frankly nobody ever
does
you know or or or or just input which
also works yes in uh terminal session
yes
okay but but the idea here the new idea
here is two things I mean and this is
closely related to progress monitor Etc
right really this is a progress I think
I'm segwaying this to something slightly
different which is a wrapper that says
put up a progress monitor for this thing
that is what is the status of us being
able to do that
there's an open PR for you know for for
the same class of things that you know
monitor can do I think
um
or no it was it was extending monitor to
to do this okay well I think this is a
worthwhile thing in other words being
able to have
you know monitoring a map for example
where there isn't a variable to talk
about we did talk about this so what
happened to that did you did you
implement something I think so I mean
okay so you know obviously it's limited
and it will slow things down I
understand that but that's okay so can
we please bring that to closure because
it really seems worthwhile well you know
we're trying to ship 13 too so I know so
I told you Stephen I told you there's an
open PR that means it's being worked on
and okay except that I know that the
Aging report for open PR's has some
pretty geriatric ones
okay well it's being worked on okay okay
that's great uh just translation for for
me
when people say an open PR and maybe I
can ask John this question I mean you
know I used to think that means it's
imminent but then somebody told me there
are PR's had been open for three years
I might have been that person it it it
goes both ways you know I mean 90 of
PR's uh
resolve within a week but uh but there's
a long tail okay all right fine if this
is not a tail animal if there's an
untailed animal I'm a happy person
it's not a tailed animal great then that
sounds excellent let's move on
font data and font measurements
that scene yeah go ahead I
font measurements
so I I don't remember the request for
this but font measurements sounds like
something that people think they want
and when they get it they realize it's
not what they wanted at all
um because people are going to assume
that if I measure the glyphs of a font
then I can come up with uh useful
information about what happens when
those glyphs appear in a word and in
fact that's not how draw a drawing of
text works
right
but there's also things like the
bounding box I mean how do you get
is it a current value if I wanted to get
the bounding box
for a piece of text the the size
rasterize has a raster size selector I
know
I know but I hate that way of doing it
I mean I think this is
what is a Rasta say what do I say here
isn't it uh quotes yeah
yeah I think that's just a rather
backwards way to do it and what I think
I'm asking for here
is perhaps just a function that gets you
out as an association
for example
a whole collection of
um
is this making any sense a whole
collection of sort of font metric
information or box metric information
uh what
do you want to be in that Association I
mean I don't know Baseline I mean the
one obvious thing that's missing here is
the Baseline
um
and by the way we used to have a
developer backtick function that
returned those three numbers and it uh
you know it didn't make the cut it was
uh people used it and I think it was
even uh uh documented for a while but uh
but you know when we uh
uh you know when we called the developer
backtech functions it didn't make the
cut
I wonder whether we did that before we
had associations
we might have
entirely possible I think we should
re-look at that with associations but I
mean you know there's all kinds of
interesting you know font data if you're
just kind of want to get data about a
given font uh
um that you know doesn't have anything
to do with measurements but uh you know
why not get it I mean we we can but but
but it's efforts and the question is is
the effort worth it how to prioritize it
yeah I don't think it's hugely I mean it
depends on how easy it is
you know if that's just some you know C
record that you could almost expose I
don't know even maybe I don't know what
is it I mean how do you how do you get
the font data from the operating system
or whatever
um well the it is operating system
specific unless uh unless we use free
type to process the fonts which can be
done but it's a little more tedious
um
um but
yeah I mean you know being able to get
things like uh uh what Unicode ranges
does the Font advertise having gliss for
what are the problems this will be very
useful what are the properties of the
fonts in terms of does the Font claim
that it has serous does it claim it has
symbols Etc you know what in in our
world of getting data on everything we
really should have this
yeah and I mean in principle I'm not
opposed in practice it's just trying to
squeeze the workload in you know right
although that could be done doesn't
require an absolutely incredibly
experienced developer
I I think that's the thing I think it's
something we should have but now this
the separate thing about measurements
you know which is kind of like
box measurements or something seems like
we should re re
invigorate that developer function
return an association and just call it
box measurements
in my view and it's an association
because we can I don't know because we
can specify a baseline position and yeah
break out break out height and depth yes
it's kind of multiple ways of saying the
same thing of course but yeah it doesn't
matter but it but something where we
return by default an association but
then you could obviously have an
individual selector like font
measurements of blah blah blah comma
depth or something comma quotes depth
and then you'd get that directly okay
but to be clear it's this is font
measurements this is
box measure you're measuring an
expression you're not made you know the
type the typeset version of expression
that's what you're measuring you're
measuring really this is the okay so
this is a separate item here and really
what this is is now box measurements
yeah
or a box
yeah
all right these are both good things all
right let's keep going
better handling of dynamic warnings and
trusted files now that's become less
I haven't noticed one of those stupid
Dynamic warnings for me personally but
that's probably because somebody just
switched it off for me
uh there was I I forget the the
situation but there was a specific uh
uh thing that was firing way more often
on your system because of how you
configured your shared drives or
something I am the details right so it
was a bug that was fixed do you think I
think so it wasn't just a wasn't just a
protection that was removed
uh so far as I know no one turned it off
universally on your system but I'm not
100 for certain
okay can I suggest that this is one of
these ux you know flow things that could
get looked at it's done like well I mean
we we have looked at it but the the pro
I mean you can't really ux your way or
uh to a better system this is this is a
technology problem and it's it requires
you know I mean a decent system
requires efforts
it's been suggested that you know oh the
cryptography team could jump in and help
out and I'm not opposed to such a
suggestion but I I haven't been able to
figure out how to make that happen
well we also lost to developer that so
that doesn't help but um
um
I mean I think at some point we should
try and figure out is there a crypto
solution to this uh there is a crypto
solution to this I I know in my head
what it would look like but just it's
just not trivial to implement
um the plumbing around it is not trivial
it's not the cryptography itself that's
not trivial right right
so there's a hash or something on the
file uh I mean basically if every uh you
know if if every installation you know
Auto generates its own private key this
might be tied of course to the user
login in the cloud or something like
that uh then you would never see uh the
warning for files that you save we could
make that happen uh and then you could
declare you know I could declare that uh
if I get a document and I believe that
document to be from Stephen Wolfram and
I can say uh you know accept all
documents from Stephen Wolfram and then
I'll never see it again for anyone but
that's what quest security certificates
and all kinds of things like that yeah
make that work yes yes exactly exactly
the but the self one doesn't require
that the self one doesn't require
Securities
um
well
I mean it's it it's still a certificate
it's just self-siting you know
so yeah so there's a secondary question
of you know uh
where you could go farther and have a a
certificate Authority and we could
designate you know certain people who
are trusted outside the company as
having the authority to create these
things and that would be interesting and
useful but yes that is definitely a tier
of and there's also a blockchain aspect
to this that we could think about and so
boy to me this seems like it's something
that might be somehow part of the whole
uh license management story as well
because this business about security you
know certificate authorities and so on
reminds me of that yeah and and we have
bits and pieces of the technology around
this uh but I think this should be fed
to I mean this is the kind of thing
maybe Andrew could look at this perhaps
to try and see whether there's a
system-wide you know thing because it's
going to require you know as you said
it's going to require server technology
et cetera et cetera et cetera Avery
could you try and feed it to another
device if you can look at this yep I can
make contact with him okay all right
let's just keep going here okay texture
mapping
yeah so yeah we're we're making progress
on this which is to say we're supporting
you know vertex texture coordinates
Arrow automatic which basically just
does what
99 of the time you wanted it to do
okay that's great all right uh and and
the uh you know it's worked for us
because we have to we have to Define
what automatic is for each new thing uh
but I know but uh but we've been making
good progress on that over the course of
130 13 1 and maybe even 13-2 I can't
remember if you did anything for 13.
we did it's moving okay can we um I know
you have to go soon so I want to just
look ahead here at some of the things
that I think are
this one glyph graphics
um so we we have the technology for this
this is just me sitting down and doing
the design if if if I spent a couple
hours doing the design I think we could
knock this out pretty quickly
um why does it need much design because
of things like baselines and so on or
what
um I mean because it's not been thought
about much except to give it various
names
um okay but does it is it correct this
works through PDF import or is it is it
more Direction not anymore there is now
a direct mechanism in the front end that
will do this
okay well this seems like
um okay fine yeah but but I mean you
know for example you might want to do
things like uh uh you know like scale
the coordinates that it uses for example
I mean it's just gonna you know build
like a random set of a random coordinate
space well and we can we can talk about
this does it put like a text Graphics or
something like that and the Prototype
build that uses he he he might have yeah
uh and with this and this comes back to
you know as I said I mean it's basically
just me sitting down working through a
proposed documentation page and I can
bring it to you know ild or LCC what I
do
um okay fine and we can probably knock
it out pretty quickly okay let's just
quickly look at these anything else here
I mean we've got other things to look at
here
but it's great function type setting I'm
not maybe
I mean it glyph graphics and text
geometry those were basically the same
thing uh so
okay
um
who refuses to go to smaller size so
I'll put this underneath it whatever
okay those are the same okay
type setting of function when there's a
single hash
so it's not hash one
I mean that's I don't know why John is
yeah that's not a front end thing that's
a that's not the front yeah that's not
the front that's a big boxes thing can
we fix that
I mean probably uh do if we really want
to I think it'd be nice
um
I can uh yeah I can take a look I think
okay all right fine let's just look at a
couple things that I know how John has
to go create full screen
oh yeah
um I I have although my name is attached
to it and it's suggested that I've
somehow participated in discussion about
this but I have no recollection what
this is supposed to be well all this is
is
it's just taking something that makes a
notebook that is full screen
okay
it's really pretty trivial
um
we should okay
right I mean is it oh yeah
why did we not do this this was an
obvious thing to do
this is really something we should do
I don't remember that being in my queue
and there's no reason there's no reason
my group has to do this I agree with you
I agree with you next I think that's
something for you
yeah we can certainly even start with a
function repository version along those
lines but then fine I think you should
plan on having this yeah you don't know
what cell would do I mean they they
would understand those books to be the
current notebook
I don't know what that doesn't make
sense really quite so and and it's now
time for me to bug out here all right
okay see you John okay thank you bye I
have to go too bye
well we can continue with a few of these
things
um
uh
I also have to cut out but I don't think
any of these involved me well then then
we should probably wrap up here I I
don't think any involved me actually
let me know if I'm wrong but okay it
seems like it seems like we have to wrap
up here
um
uh unless there's anything here that is
um
yeah I mean there there was a note I was
just going to mention that last week we
talked about uh Hardware based random
number generation and Avery and I did a
little digging into that and as far as
we can tell no one's actually been
looking into it we talked to Rob and Tom
and Mark and Dave and you know Rob said
as long as we can feed in a bit stream
it's not hard to hook in to the random
functions but it looks like if that was
a project that we wanted to be bouncing
around so far no one's done anything
with it
um okay I mean maybe that's the thing
with Christopher's modern Library
linking mechanisms that there's an easy
way to do it well you know I was about
to mention well
maybe two related things the first thing
is I think in the cryptography packlet
there at least was a way of hooking into
open ssls uh supposedly
cryptographically secure pseudonym
number generator which might be using I
mean I'd imagine it it should be using
some kind of Hardware Randomness if it
can I don't know if it is
um but I think there's a there's a
function in some internal context that
that does that there's also there's like
uh some documentation examples about
calling that same function using the
compiler stuff but
but I think that functionality already
exists in some internal context maybe
you could try and find it and then
feed that back
um
okay
uh
let's just have a quick look through
here and I can tell you which of these
are
um
a thing
I thought we were doing something on
this in the cloud yeah probably not I
know Kevin Daly has a prototype for date
Setter or at least building a tool set
for it and I believe there's a Geo
Setter for the cloud or at least a you
know the the standard sort of way so
Avery go chase this I we don't know
let's let's get some more data on what's
going on with this one okay yeah
that's for John
huh
I'm assuming that's some sort of
connection speed between the front end
internal I don't know no I think that
the connection speed
I have no idea I'm guessing from the
name it could be either a connection
speed tester
which will be kind of interesting to
have
um
unuseful
you know given a given a URL just like
we can do a ping time but if we say you
know
ping time
whatever it is www.wolf.com
right
[Music]
um
having connection speed measurement
would be useful
let's see if we can't go into like your
speedtest.net or whatever that checks
ping time to
yeah but I mean connection speed is a is
a different thing I mean ping time is
what it is
and connection speed is the throughput
right upload download rate Etc yeah
right here
yeah we we won't be able to do
oh yeah we
yes we can do both of them right we can
do upload I mean download speed
I don't know how it works because this
is CMP packets right so download speed I
I don't know how those work and I could
imagine that the packet transfer speeds
for CMP and UDP and TCP and so on are
all different
I think we should look at that but
that's nothing to do with the front-end
group
okay so okay anybody here know how to
there's a question
I don't know we need to find somebody
who just knows this like somebody from
the systems team or something who just
knows how you do this yeah again I can
certainly ask for him you know what we
have in curl length but I could also
check with
you said the the systems team and see
yes what we actually used to measure
that fine
that's fine maybe there's a library we
can just link to that just does this
it seems useful to me okay
especially because we've got nice units
and blah blah blah you know seems useful
okay
what the heck is this doing this Roger
well
I don't this is a John thing we're gonna
have to ask him
drag receiver
that is the whole drag and drop
subsystem developed like 15 years ago
and never finished
and there's a certain argument that we
should at least get wfr versions of it
Avery that's the thing for you to Chase
this is basically the placeholder of
drop the file here drop the image here
Etc
as an interface well actually this is
different
but this one is different that that one
is what you just said which makes a lot
of sense
that one seems very useful the other is
the full drag and drop system which Teo
developed probably 15 years ago
and if nobody else knows where that code
is tail would know where the code is
and Taylor's back with us although in a
different capacity
um
and uh
um
I would recommend for this drag receiver
stuff and drag and drop and so on I
think given the modern world of function
repository we could try and put a
version of it in the function Repository
Avery that's something for you to Chase
okay this image drag receiver just seems
very useful and not very hard
and that's for John
okay
any comments about that
that again
seems useful but I mean maybe I don't
know
no that's not for wfr that's a thing
that that is new that's a it's one thing
we've talked to him about it okay
um
yeah there's a few more items here Avery
please you know prune this appropriately
okay for the next time we do this
meeting and have John and it makes sense
Avery yep yep
Ah that's very useful and important
okay uh
well was Ricardo here I mean HTTP what
is this thing here
so he's on the attendees there
give me a second to the United set
foreign
I've been told that d-trend is naive
yeah I think we talked about it briefly
um I wanted to include the
if we were going to talk about the stats
things we have Gosha who could jump in
um but like we said the
hello
hi okay this thing here HTTP response
function method dispatcher Etc
well method dispatch showcase seems to
be pretty straightforward I'm not sure
about HTTP response function
what is it is there an HTTP response
function right now
no I don't think so
okay
um but so this is
okay well this is something like URL
dispatcher but it Dispatch over the
method
so I guess it can be nested with other
stuff we already have
so here I'll dispatcher dispatches on
the path and this will be a Dispatch
over the method
seems reasonable to me
right uh sure not sure what it should do
when you
don't provide enough rule or the method
is wrong there must be some kind of
fallback so in that case
but what is anything else to I mean
I mean I guess you would do you could
use a blank to Define it but I mean if
you don't Define anything no no I
understand if the method isn't there
then it does nothing presumably uh well
nothing you need to return some kind of
responsibility 400 400 something yeah
yeah so I mean that makes sense and the
if it isn't it's just not available
right so
okay like a reasonable thing is it hard
to implement
well no not really
um hard as usual is to the documentation
and I mean yeah stuff like that but yeah
okay
priority but I think we can take it so
this is going to happen then in some way
um but I'm not sure what is HTTP
response function I Let's ignore it we
don't know what it is I think it was an
alternative name for this you like the
name HTTP method dispatcher
is probably the right name for it
right
right if it's like H URL dispatcher
yeah it would be the same it would be
the analog of that so it would be either
only metal dispatched shot but maybe
it's too generic
dispatcher yeah I've got to call it HTTP
method okay so I think that's the right
name for it I'm not sure if I can delete
this why are these things uneditable are
they honored no they're not
looks good to me
okay uh anything else here that we can
cover
with the people who are available yeah
so the the last one is kind of a quick
point but we've had a couple of
um people ask about you know information
has this internal Association that lives
inside of it that has keys and values
associated with it and there's not
currently an extractor to say basically
give me all the data that's in for
that's within information without
typesetting you know you can
structurally extract it I don't want to
encourage that what are some names of
what are some um
so I think that one of the proposals was
to have all as a key you know currently
information's keys are all strings so a
symbol would be distinct but that isn't
a hard and fast rule
uh I think all is fine or or Property
association but is that is how close
this Property association
I mean usually we have things like data
set
um
representing put this in a data set and
Property association is the kind of
thing you have right there yeah a
Property association would mirror What
entity value does for example where
you know we'd have the the keys with the
properties and then the values
all right
well I think having data set and
Property association and all wouldn't be
terrible
okay yeah that gives some flexibility
someone proposed doing normal which I
don't really like because yeah yeah no
bad idea
um
okay all right we made good progress
here today
um Avery will prune this for the next
time we have to continue on it yeah and
uh almost all done with all the low
hanging as as little low hanging as some
of it was
huh that's interesting are there not
previous files that this was really
everything
uh this was everything that was left so
we've gone through like 100 items from
no I I'm aware but I mean I'm just
asking the question
weren't there things that were
um
what is it called
it's the okay so we had this thing
called designs
okay and which is this is this green
lighted longer this is low hanging zero
two and the the other variations of it
okay but like things like this or under
consideration 01
those were looked at
okay we need to do that
okay so basically what I think we should
do
is
take this whole section take this whole
thing here
um
and I have no idea what that is for
example
oh gosh we're still working on these
things you've got to go through this
whole directory and what I think we
should do
is
move things
you know into
yeah I mean there's things here
that are done that are not done
Etc we've got more to do here
okay and also
this here
there's a bunch of things here as well
okay
and we looked at this
no not recently no okay well let's do
that another one of these meetings
I mean we've done a lot of stuff here a
lot of stuff is done
that's a good idea
now this is important this one is
important this has a lot of worthwhile
stuff in it
Ah that's an interesting idea as well
okay well we've got more to do but we're
making good progress so can't complain
um all right anything else here
oh okay and I mean clearly when we've
done these I think these are the next
step let's do these and then we should
go back to wfr promotion
okay
yep sounds good to me okay good work all
right see you guys soon